There’s a horror movie I love,
where no one’s allowed to talk
because scary monsters will hear them
and eat them, and it’s fantastic,
but a main character has a cochlear implant,
and they get the depiction all wrong.
Which is a shame, because cochlear implants
are fascinating and ingenious devices,
and because it breaks the movie for me.
So what are cochlear implants, exactly,
and how can they help
even the profoundly deaf hear?
A cochlear implant is a medical device that
goes, as the name suggests, inside your cochlea.
Quick refresher: that’s the spiral structure
of three fluid-filled canals
coiled up like a snail’s shell in your inner ear, past
the eardrum, hammer, anvil, and stirrup.
In one canal, there are hair cells along the
length of the spiral.
At the base of the spiral, the hair cells
respond to higher frequency sounds,
and at the apex, they move at low frequencies.
These movements trigger nerve cells, converting
the sound waves to electrical impulses
and passing the signal on to the brain for processing.
That’s just a basic overview of how it all
works... assuming it does work.
The most common form of hearing loss is sensorineural,
where the hair cells, nerves, or brain
aren't functioning like they do in a hearing person.
Sensorineural hearing loss can be caused by
a lot of things, such as age, loud noises,
trauma, disease, or genetics.
Sometimes it can be treated with a hearing
aid, which is basically just an amplifier
that boosts the volume of speech while cutting
down on background noise.
But when a hearing aid is not enough, a cochlear
implant may do the trick.
Instead of getting the outer and middle ear
to transmit sound waves like a hearing aid
does, a cochlear implant goes straight to
the finish line.
It consists of two parts: a speech processor
and the actual implant.
The speech processor sits on the back of the
ear and is just what it sounds like: it takes
the sounds it hears and converts them to
electrical signals.
Those signals are sent to the implant, which
rests under the skin and connects to the
speech processor outside via a magnet.
The implant has a long array of electrodes
that actually curl up inside the cochlea,
and when these electrodes go off, they trigger
the nerve cells like the hair normally would.
Even though the device itself isn’t making
any noise, the brain interprets the electrical
pulses it pipes in as though it were sound,
and, just like that, people can start to make
out speech when before they were in a world
of complete silence.
Hear that, John Krasinski?
They make no sound!
I’m still really bothered by that.
It’s not a perfect replica of speech, and
it’s not the same
as having a full range of hearing.
The cochlea has thousands of hair cells, while
a cochlear implant only has a couple dozen
electrodes, and they can activate overlapping
regions of neurons, so the tones of speech
and music get blurred together.
Programs that help the speech processor to
encode tone and timbre can aid music recognition,
and by mapping an individual's cochlea, scientists
can improve speech recognition by actually
turning off certain electrodes that were activating
unintended neurons.
Cochlear implants are a topic of fierce debate
within the Deaf community, and plenty of people
who are deaf prefer not to have them, because
they live happy lives and are part of a community.
For others, though, they can’t picture their
lives without one.
Either way, I think we can all agree they’re
a marvel of science and technology.
And that A Quiet Place was great, but they
could have spent five seconds
googling “Cochlear Implants.”
If we're comin' in loud and co-clear, be sure
to click that subscribe button.
And, on the topic of audio, did you ever wonder
what's happening in your brain
when you hear someone scream?
Trace explains in this episode why your body
goes into a whole cascade of defensive responses
when you hear it.
Be sure to subscribe to Seeker, and thanks
for watching.